let's talk about let's move on what's
happening in the united states because
we got this this story um
i don't know how to feel about this
this is uh let me read the title the
guardian one dead and five wounded in
portland shooting during protest in park
authorities describe confrontation in
normandale park between a homeowner and
participants in police violence protests
now
i don't know how to feel about it
because
the conflict itself the the fighting the
shooting of course is just outright bad
regular people defying antifa far
leftist and saying get out of my
neighborhood is people waking up to the
crisis and refusing to to you know
refusing and rejecting it
but it leads to this and this is what's
scary because we don't we don't we don't
want shooters on our streets you know
the people the people who um they post
stuff
you know there's that joke around and
find out and i'm like man you really
don't want to find out no matter who you
are you might wear the shirt you might
wear the hat we joking we have a joke
shirt says step on snack and find out
the reality is
i assure you you don't want to find out
you know the people who think that you
know they will get into a conflict have
a good time of it you don't want to be
worried about your kids because you
might think you're tough you might think
you're brave but what about when's your
kid who's at home and these people are
fighting in the streets so stories like
this man
i like the idea that regular people are
saying no to the far left i don't like
the idea that it's resulting in this but
i feel like this may be inevitable so
here's the story just to give you a
quick summary
these antifa far leftists they're doing
their marches as they normally do
they were armed
reportedly according to them and um some
you know other witnesses opposed but i
don't trust them so what they said was
this guy comes up to him screaming at
him saying they're terrorists and
they're the cause of all the violence
and that if they go near his house he
will shoot them
and then
abruptly open fired
shooting uh six people one of them died
five are injured and then they
critically injured him
they then go on to claim to the press
they were unarmed yet this guy's
critically wounded they claimed that he
just attacked them i don't believe any
of it if i were to make you know my
assessment based off what i know about
the far left extremists these antifa
types i'd say that
you know look there's a video of these
guys pulling a guy out of his truck and
beating him
they were armed with rifles they were
blocking an intersection the guy was
honking at him said get out of the way
apparently the guy saw their guns showed
him that he was strapped they pointed
weapons at him he said tried he pulled
his gun pointed at them then they
grabbed him and started beating him how
much you want to bet something similar
happened this time the only thing is
this time the guy was like i ain't
playing any games and that woman is dead
and this guy might die as well so this
kind of stuff gets scary man but it i
don't know what you what your thoughts
on the uh thoughts on this are larry
because you mentioned you read stephen
marsh's book on civil war where do you
think what do you think about this where
do you think this is all going if we
don't create someone who will step up
and say
look what you just said right your your
thought process is exactly correct we
need people to think how you're thinking
this isn't i don't want efron to find
out right i don't want to find out and
it's an example of someone who did and
it hurt everybody like nobody won in
this right a bunch of people went to the
hospital somebody died this is lose-lose
someone's got to step up and go wait a
minute okay i get you're mad let's talk
this damn thing out and that's an
important piece and i hope we begin to
do that and the only way we do that is
by having someone like what you're
talking about say hey can we not fight
can we not do that if i was the mayor of
the town
and i've got antifa out or blm out or
january 6 people whatever i got
or i'm
trudeau and i got truckers
i don't walk away
i literally go there i physically go
there and say i hear you you got an
issue or a problem or concern i'm gonna
give you a time and a place we can talk
about this and let's try to make this
happen
you start doing that more and more over
time this is
the damage has been done has been done
for so long it doesn't it isn't fixed by
one guy doing one thing
it needs multiple people doing this
often this should be the norm we should
make protest anger
when they do it we respond with okay
what's wrong versus i will hammer you
when you respond with i will hammer you
they become desperate desperate people
do desperate things it's just human
nature what did
jefferson say when i'm gonna get it
wrong when peace pro protest is
impossible violent revolution is
inevitable did i get that right was it
was it kennedy i thought that was
jefferson those who made a peaceful
revolution impossible make violent
revolution inevitable thank you there we
go i thank you for doing it right yes
yeah but i don't know
look up who said it because you know
we'll make sure but so i want to make it
possible kennedy kennedy i want to go
out of my way i want to make it possible
and executives have to do this it must
be mayors governors county executives as
a nation we don't pay attention to
congressmen or senators we don't we only
pay attention to executives they have to
be the ones doing this but i i don't
want to be i don't want to now bring up
the the the pessimism here but
when we were talking with stephen you
know the point i made he said something
similar it's like when will you and your
country realize you're tearing each
other apart you need to come together
and i said to him you know you're
canadian right he says yes i'm like you
you like your socialized health care and
he said right i said okay abolish it go
full private free market and we got
peace
and he said
point taken right he's like i won't give
that up ever for anything and so for me
you know these these individuals for
instance these antifa types
they are uh
consistently violent they are
consistently extreme and they are of the
the political faction that uh for
instance in california tried to repeal
their civil rights legislation from
their own constitution
and they were they nearly succeeded in
doing so
when that comes up
i just got to say i'm sorry there's
there's no circumstance in which i
negotiate with that person and say we'll
take away some of the civil rights
potential it's not going to happen i
felt like they didn't exist until 2016
antifa i never even heard of it until
2015 they they did uh they were at
occupy wall street we just called it you
know the black block element it seems
like it's a response to hillary
clinton's dnc screwing over bernie
sanders and ripping any hope from that
party and then the federal reserve
printing insane amounts of money and
devaluing the currency these people have
no hope and now they're out there
covered lockdown smashing stuff up
because they can finally be outside but
if we focus on the problems like that i
think that we can quell the violence and
calm people down
you're right ian what happens with these
people is they're uh despondent dejected
they're angry they feel there's no path
forward and then along comes a demagogue
who says your answer is communism they
adopt it and then we now have an
expansive force of people who have
identified the problem even they've
identified a certain
thing as the problem that's not really
their problem
they they
unfortunately
will often side with the very
establishment that has caused them these
problems and led them down these this
path like you mentioned you know hillary
clinton and all that stuff yeah they
they'll they'll come out and be like we
hate the democrats and then you'll get
someone like contra points for instance
saying but you have to vote for joe
biden i'm like
look my thought on donald trump for 2020
was
i can choose the the ivory tower elites
who gutted this country or the ball
rampaging through the ivory tower i'll
take the ball you know let them run
around and kick some stuff over for once
and otherwise what we go back to square
one yeah but you brought up a very valid
point here people always think you know
how how bad does that have to get
before people revolt
there's no answer that because people
will stay in horrible situations forever
it's a it's a phenomenon called learned
helplessness what they require is hope
was what you just said and some
demagogue gives hope right the best
example i can give you is russia 1917.
peasants forever 300 years
no real revolts i mean here are there
some sporadic revolts but no real
revolts with 300 years here comes lenin
hey how about is a communism thing and
all they knew was what can't be worse
than this right right sadly they were
wrong it was but they didn't know that
they had hope and the hope was oh this
guy he's telling us something it's not
what we got now we know what we got now
sucks and we've been sitting in 300
years okay let's try this communism
thing
and it was basically the same thing for
them different name though um and nice
nicer flags so there was some benefit i
guess to it but that's about it maybe
some emotional satisfaction there was
some of that sure absolutely so they you
get that i think it happens here too and
if two sides are fighting
there has to be some hope and that's the
third party thing the reason why i think
and i am blatantly biased i know i'm
biased the libertarian party i think the
liberty movement is the answer because
it's the only movement where you don't
have to
convert
you can be as liberal or as conservative
as you want to be
just don't force your view on others you
want to have a commune good have your
commune over there just make sure
government isn't paying for it we'll
make government smaller do your commune
and you'll be fine you want to have more
free market we can have that too we can
have all of those things if we change
the environment right now we can't
change the environment the reason why
people get so angry is because they
realize this
if the other guy wins he or she will
enforce their will upon me
which means i must take less of two
evils
but uh
i mean some of these people are
authoritarians yes so but the but the
people aren't authoritarians i don't the
leadership are what people want is
someone who will save
them or make them feel better with their
lives better solve their problems now
you might say to yourself but larry
they're voting for you know
um authoritarians
people don't want freedom i don't i
don't mean to be cruel people want
happiness
people want happiness not freedom if
freedom if they believe freedom will get
them happiness they'll vote for freedom
if they think some dictator will get
them happiness they'll vote for a
dictator they will vote for whatever
they believe will get them happiness our
job in the liberty movement is to show
them that freedom is the answer so they
vote for it i completely agree but i do
think there are authoritarians who enjoy
being authoritarian true awesome and and
you know
man this story i told before we got a
funny update on it and it's a good
example when i went to a sushi
restaurant with my girlfriend and we
walk in
it's very small the sushi restaurant is
maybe like
30 feet by 30 feet maybe
everyone's sitting down no one's wearing
a mask but there's a mask mandate so we
walk in oh yeah and the guy grabs a
couple of menus and he goes you need to
wear masks and then i went oh nobody's
wearing any masks and he was like oh but
you have to wear it and i was like
i don't understand like nobody's wearing
masks while they're sitting down and
eating
and i said okay the table was literally
about six seven feet in front of us i
was like we'll sit right there and then
we'll eat and he goes okay but if you
get up you have to wear a mask so he
hand i'm like yeah no problem he hands
me and my girlfriend a mask and i say
okay
we're literally three seconds from
sitting down when a person at the
counter goes put the mask on and i was
like i'm just gonna sit down literally
right here it's a couple and they were
like no put the mask on and i said are
you serious and all of the staff
simultaneously went yes
here's the funny thing about it we got
an update
this mask mandate was in frederick
county and it went into effect i believe
just uh after new year's in january
now they've rescinded the mask mandate
abruptly about a month later
why yeah oh well cases are down in a
month what you enact it and then repeal
it like instantly
the the people there just do as they're
told they have no interest in thinking
about the problem thinking about the
policy or thinking about how psychotic
it was they were doing this the only
thing in their mind was whether they
like it or not was adhere to the
authority or get out and so we did
so when you have i i feel like the
culture war and the crisis work we're
facing is you know types like antifa for
instance that are willing to go around
with rifles and tell people you can't
drive down this road anymore anymore
chanting who streets our streets forcing
people off of public property
they want to they want to use power
against other people i don't i kind of
like to mind my own business which is
why we're in the middle of nowhere with
a bunch of chickens
get away from everybody else leave me
alone right so i love the liberty
movement stuff but i do feel like
you know the question that came up with
that with steven was
these people won't
they they want to rule over you they
want to and so if you take the approach
of if only you just left me alone
they'll say i will and then they'll
still
try to impose their will on you i
suppose the the quote is when i am weak
i ask you for freedom because that is
according to your principles when i am
strong i deny you freedom because that's
according to mine and that's what we
fear with these types of groups yeah
what i would argue is i'm sorry i'm just
going to ask like what is the
libertarian approach to a mob that is
equally authoritarian and unreasonable
yep like what's the approach to that so
let me cover two pieces if i could the
first one is i think what people want
more than anything this is universal
it's purpose
purpose is critical yeah so when i don't
have purpose when i feel without power
when i feel like i don't have anything
to do and also the government says your
purpose is to make sure people wear
marshmallows on their heads
you will go out of your way to make sure
people are wearing marshmallows on their
head you won't care why you won't care
what they're doing just i have purpose
and i have power i'm going to make sure
you put marshmallows in your head so i
think that's the real issue if we give
them other forms of purpose they'll go
there people want to feel useful people
want to feel important people want to
feel empowered people want purpose the
problem is we've shut people down for
two years sucked away their purpose for
two years and the only thing they have
is
marching in the streets i mean there
weren't this many activists before kovid
why they had to be at work at nine
o'clock in the morning that was their
purpose right well now you don't got to
go to work anymore what am i doing oh
janie's yelling about anti what's andiva
i don't know let's go
and they're doing it right oh we get to
have guns oh my god now we're all
powerful so again there are leaders but
the perfect storm was shutting
everything down and creating a bunch of
young men particularly but also young
women who had no purpose so they will go
do whatever is required my goal is to
create more purpose for more people less
of them will be in the streets less of
them will be trying to impose their will
because they have other things to do
that's the thing i'm never going to stop
the the authoritarian
can i lessen them yes can i make their
recruitment a whole lot harder yes
bad people are bad people but they're
nothing without armies
so if i shut their recruitment down i
make everything better thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time